it's been over three months since i made
my last high-end imac leaks video and
while i'm still firm on some of my
predictions like there being no way that
the display size will go up to 32 inches
as well as being 100 sure about the chin
sticking around
i do want to admit that i've completely
changed my mind on a very important
aspect of the imac the performance as i
was researching for my m1 max quadro mac
pro leaks video i came across a quote
from a really old mark german article
from 2020 that i completely forgot about
he said that for the next gen chip
targeting macbook pro and imac models
apple is working on designs with as many
as 16 power cores and four efficiency
cores yes that would mean up to a 20
core chip in the upcoming apple silicon
imac whereas i previously thought that
apple would simply pop in the same m1
max chip as we have in the macbook pros
and call it good but now that we finally
have the m1 max in our hands i started
to realize that apple is much more
likely to give us a 20 core m1 max duo
chip option by literally combining two
m1 max dies into one package to create a
monster chip as you can see illustrated
right here by frederick orange on
twitter so before i get into the
overwhelming evidence for this
conclusion i've got to discuss two
things first off i gotta admit that luke
miani was right and second i've gotta go
through the other changes to the leaks
and rumors in terms of the design and
everything else first off the display
analyst ross young on twitter was
basically the only source that predicted
that the new macbook pros would get
120hz pro motion mini led displays
maintaining his 100 leak accuracy rating
and less than a month ago he tweeted out
that the upcoming imac releasing in the
first quarter of next year will have a
27 inch mini led display with 120 hertz
pro motion technology now i know a lot
of people were hoping for a 32 inch
display and i was personally hoping for
a 30 inch so 27 inches sounds a bit
disappointing but if you think about it
having mini led technology and 120 hertz
promotion is huge and having a 27 inch
display will make it cheaper to
manufacture so i completely trust ross
on this leak now this also means that
the chin is staying around 100
guaranteed but the entire chassis will
be smaller to give us slim bezels around
the 27 inch display similar to the size
of the bezels of the 24 inch imac now i
ended up looking through some very old
leaks and i found a golden nugget from
ming chi kuo from way back in march of
2020 when he said that apple was working
on six mini led products three of which
we already have today like the ipads and
the macbook pros but the curious thing
is that he claimed that apple was
working on a 27-inch mini led
imac pro which now perfectly matches up
to ross young's leak but the only weird
thing is the imac pro part but now that
i'm thinking about it it actually makes
sense if the new imac is in fact coming
with up to an m1 max duo chip which
would quite literally give it insane
amounts of performance as i'll show you
very soon so if it becomes the imac pro
then my initial idea of the larger imac
having white bezels to match the 24 inch
goes out the window since it's
technically in a different class and so
it's gonna have black bezels for sure as
well as coming in a space gray color
which is conveniently missing as an
option on the current 24 inch m1 imac so
that perfectly matches up as well
however i don't think that apple is
going to create two separate 27 inch
imacs like in the past one for prosumers
and one for real professionals i think
they're literally going to combine both
of those machines into one product so
the prosumers will have less expensive
options at the lower price range but the
real professionals can go all out with
an m1 max duo chip that is worthy of the
imac pro title and then if you really
think about it calling this 27 inch imac
the imac pro will finally end the
confusion between the smaller and larger
imac since people will know that the
smaller 24 inch model is always the
regular imac and the larger one is
always the imac pro so with that said
here's a render by ian zelbo that
perfectly matches up to my expectations
for the design of this new upcoming imac
now before i get into my expectations
for the pricing performance and how
apple will fit this m1 max duo chip into
the chassis i want to go through the
various reasons why it makes sense for
apple to pack in a duo chip instead of
just using the same m1 max from the
macbook pros but first i want to mention
that only around 27 of you guys are
subscribed so if you haven't already
click that subscribe button below to
help us reach our goal of 1 million subs
before the end of the year we would
greatly appreciate it getting back to
the imac the apple tree on twitter
recently put up an article making a very
good point about the future apple
silicon imac the current intel 27-inch
imac can be configured with up to 128
gigs of ram and there's only one way for
the current apple silicon building
blocks to achieve 128 gigs of system
memory and that is of course with an m1
max duo chip which has double the memory
blocks as you can see in this image
giving you up to 128 gigs of unified
memory and i personally believe that
this is going to be very important
because if apple only gave us an m1 max
ship with 64 gigs of ram people would
call it a downgrade compared to the
previous intel imac that can go up to
128 making apple silicon seem inferior
at least in terms of ram capacity so an
m1 max duo would totally make sense now
getting into the second reason that
various people pointed out including the
apple tree and luke miyani the current
m1 max chip isn't much faster than the
highest end 5700 xt gpu in the intel
imac with 10.4 t flops of performance
compared to 7.6 and that honestly
doesn't sound like that great of an
improvement switching from intel to
apple silicon so therefore
if apple wants to blow people away with
impressive performance charts like they
did with the macbook pros they'd likely
want much more performance by giving you
an m1 max duo chip with a 64 core gpu
but the even bigger point is when you
consider the differences in raw cpu
performance the current 27 inch intel
imac actually has two cpu options that
have more cpu performance than the 10
core m1 max as you can see in the
cinemage r23 chart with the i9 being 14
faster in terms of full 100 cpu
workloads so if apple was only giving us
a 10 core chip there would literally be
a downgrade going from intel to apple
silicon at least in terms of raw cpu
performance and i don't think there's
any way that apple is going to be okay
with this apple instead wants to show
off mind-blowing differences compared to
intel which the m1 max duo chip would
achieve and you've also got to remember
that intel just released their alder
lake chips which are very impressive so
apple literally needs a 20 core and one
max duo in order to stay competitive now
moving on to my fourth point if apple
limits the imac to just the 10 core m1
max then the fully loaded imac price
will be significantly lower than the
current intel imac so if apple's imac
starts at two thousand dollars with a
bend eight core cpu and 14 core gpu just
like the base 14 inch macbook pro then a
maxed out m1 max imac with a 10 core cpu
32 core gpu 64 gigs of unified ram and
an 8 terabyte ssd will cost around 5 900
however a current intel imac can be
configured up to 8
200
since you have the option for 128 gigs
of ram which is 2300 higher than a
theoretical m1 max apple silicon version
so if apple wants as much revenue
potential as possible to make their
sales numbers look good they need to
give us a more expensive m1 max duo chip
option and then finally this next point
is perhaps the most overwhelming
evidence we have for a 20 court ship
going into the imac according to hector
martin an engineer that is working on
porting linux to apple silicon max the
irq controller in the m1 pro and max
chips is very clearly engineered with a
currently unused second half for a
second die specifically there's a second
set of config mask software gen hardware
state registers that are currently idle
in the new macbook pros showing evidence
that apple has already done the prep
work in the latest mac os monterey
software to support a theoretical m1 max
duo apple silicon champ and hector
believes in this so strongly that he's
already working on supporting this
two-die chip ahead of time so that linux
just boots up without issues on future
two die machines but the biggest piece
of overwhelming evidence is that the
current irq controller only has support
for two dies and not four and at this
point we're almost 100 sure that the
2022 mac pro will have four dies
according to mark german's reliable
leaks and rumors so what this ultimately
means is that apple is waiting for next
year's version of mac os to build in
four-dice support but since we already
have two-die chip support in the current
mac os monterey release this is
overwhelming evidence for an m1 max duo
imac coming early next year so with all
of that said here's how i think apple
will pull this chip off they're simply
going to grab two m1 max dies and
package them together into one soc
package using some sort of infinity
fabric to connect the two dies and since
the larger imac is expected to be
thicker than the current 24 inch imac i
expect apple to place this larger
package behind the display and right
above the chin with heat pipes leading
from the dies down to the chin area
which has much more available volume for
large heat sinks and fans along with the
rest of the components like the i o
ports and the speakers but now getting
into the performance we should expect
out of this new m1 max duo chip i
expected to scale really well compared
to the regular m1 max with only up to
around 10 efficiency loss due to the
infinity fabric connection between dies
so here's an updated cinebench r23 chart
with the 20 core m1 max duo greatly
outperforming the highest end i9 in the
current imac and then here's a chart
with the maxed out 64 core and one max
gpu showing the results in gfx bench 5.0
metal with basically three times higher
graphics performance and then on top of
all of that you've also got to factor in
all the benefits from the unified memory
architecture which allowed the m1 max
macbook pro to outperform our 15 000 mac
pro in various performance tests even
though it has less raw performance like
we showed you in our recent comparison
video which you should definitely check
out and i also want to remind you that
the m1 max duo will come with double the
memory bandwidth so 800 gigabytes per
second compared to 400 thanks to having
64 channel memory compared to 32 on the
m1 max as well as a maximum of
128 gigs of unified memory which can be
used as vram compared to 64. it'll also
come with four amx matrix multiplication
code processors compared to two
eight thunderbolt 4 controllers instead
of four
two active 16 core neural engines
instead of two and double the amount of
video encoders and decoders including
the pro res ones which will greatly
speed up video editing performance and
now with all that said let's get into
the expected spec options and the
release date now the base specs really
depend on the price target that apple
wants to hit with the imac so if they
want to hit a 2 000 price target like
the 14 inch macbook pro to appeal to the
prosumers out there then it'll likely
come with a binned 8 core and 14 core
gpu m1 pro chat however they could
instead bring the base price up to maybe
2 300
with a non-bin chip if they really
wanted to and then going from there
you'll of course be able to configure to
the higher end m1 max ship but when you
go to the duo you'll be required to
upgrade to 64 gigs of ram and i think
they might give us an option for a bend
16 core cpu m1 max duo chip which is
essentially two eight core dies put
together with a minimum of a 48 core gpu
which is two bend 24 core gpu dies put
together and these will of course
require 64 gigs of ram and then finally
you'll be able to upgrade to the full 20
cpu cores the full 64 gpu cores and the
full 128 gigs of ram which will
obviously be very expensive and as far
as the release date it needs to happen
at an official apple event because this
will obviously be a huge deal and since
ross young said it's going to be coming
in the first quarter of 2022 this points
directly at an apple march event reveal
now the only other question remaining is
the fact that we had a very old leak
about apple creating their own custom
gpu codenamed lifuka and one of my
twitter followers dr steve pointed out
that lyfuca translates to an island so
it could be a code name for the chopped
off bottom portion of the m1 max dies
which apple can collect and combine
together into large gpu packages to
further boost gpu performance but i
honestly don't know much about this
right now i'm just leaving it open as a
possibility but there you guys go that
was my video admitting that i was wrong
about the imac not getting a better m1
max duo chip which now makes more sense
with all of the information that we have
available today so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video and if you disagree
with any of my points go ahead and leave
a comment down below and i do want to
mention that you can check out our merch
like this i want max soc shirt down
below and we also got some new stickers
like this notchbook pro design so
definitely check it out and if you're
not already subscribed do so right now
by clicking the circle above and
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
you